لم تكن فضيمه تتوقع يوما ان تعيش وقد بلغت
من الكبر عتيا رعبا كالذي عاشته اثناء
الزلزلين اللذين ضربا البلاد في السادس من
فبراير تقول فاديما انها كانت مستيقظه فجر
ذلك اليوم لكن قدميها اللتين لا تقويان
اصلا على حملها تسمرتا في الارض من هول
الموقف
شعرنا بخوف شديد انا وزوجي قلت له سامحني
ان قصرت يوما في حقك وقال هو الشيء نفسه
والبيت يهتزجنا بشده لا توصف
بيت فضيمه فنقلت مع بعض افراد اسرتها الى
هذه السفينه التي حولت الى ماوى للمتضررين
من الزلزال
نصطحبها الى جهه نافذه وقد ارادت ان ترى
ملامح قريتها المدمره ولو من بعيد
انا الان في امان ولله الشكر لا ياخذ
الروح الا من وهبها
عشرات العائلات نقلت الى هنا بعد الزلزال
ممن لم يجدوا ماواه تتسع هذه السفينه
لاكثر من الف شخص وفيها 400 غرفه يعمل
كوكانت مديرا لاحد الموانئ وهو من ضمن
فريق حكوميا مهمته انشاء البنيه التحتيه
لنقل الغاز الطبيعي المستخرج من البحر
الاسود الى البر
شانتيه
استاجرنا هذه السفينه المخصصه للرحلات
السياحيه قبل الزلزال ببضعه اشهر لتكون
مكان اقامه لعمالنا وقررنا الان ان تكون
الاولويه هي لمواطنين المتضررين من
الزلزال خصوصا لمن لم يجدوا ينامون فيها
هدفنا التخفيف عن مواطنين وخصوصا الاطفال
الذين عاشوا تجربه صعبه
تحتوي السفينه على مرافق عده بينها صاله
اطعام كبيره واخرى اجتماعيه ورياضيه وصاله
سينما وهي اشبه ما تكون بمدينه صغيره
عائمه فلا قلق هنا ربما من زلزال يضرب
مجددا او من هزات ارتداديه مع كبر حجم
الاضرار الناجمه عن الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا تبدو الحاجه ملحه لتسخير ما يمكن من
امكانات لايواء المتضررين وتشكل هذه
السفينه ومثيلاتها جزءا من جهود الايواء
ولو بصفه مؤقته
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره من ميناء
اسكندرون